what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i have a
special guest
my friend helena she's on tick tock her
tic toc is in the description if you
guys want to check it out
she has never heard of kevin samuels and
i'm going to be showing her
kevin samuel's most viral clip today for
the very first time are you excited i'm
excited
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel as you guys
know i'm trying to hit 20
000 subscribers this month and i need
each and every one of you while you're
at it bring that notification
bell you're going to be notified of my
daily videos
all right guys this is your average at
best
what are your what are your thoughts
already are you nervous no
okay i want to see what it's about he
seems like he's got a lot of followers
so he has um a show that people call
into so these women want like dating
advice
okay oh that's cool
she has no idea guys she has no idea
okay can you hear me can you hear me now
those were hers hey can you hear me
yeah oh no
i'm a phd how many dogs you got
uh one really
i'm sorry what kind of dog is it he's a
cane corso
he seems nice he's a what a cane corso
what is that in english um
it's a larger dog and their breed is
meant for
gardening and protecting they're very
protective of their home and their
families
so what's your disagreement um honestly
i don't have a disagreement i just came
here because i honestly want some advice
from you
it says disagreement day i know this is
my first time catching
on live normally i'm asleep and um you
have a job
i do i own a business okay so i do too
and i do have a question but i have a
business
and if you wanted my advice you could
always book a session if you can't catch
us
at the show live i'm definitely i was
trying to go online
um earlier but all you have to do man
but see
what kind of business do you want dang
what do you think so far
i mean is he gonna answer her questions
or is he gonna give her
the run around um i think he does end up
answering her question
but this he has different days okay so i
think she just she wanted advice
i know but it sounds like he couldn't
catch she didn't catch him on
disagreement day but right
so he's a nice voice at least some
people okay so
what you're basically trying to do is i
have a disagreement day and you
basically came in and said damn your
topic
i want to ask you what i want to ask you
and that's
but you are more than welcome to go on
my website and purchase your time to
talk with me one on one
because what you're trying to do is
rather rude but i will go ahead and do
it because i'm going to use this as a
teaching lesson
how old are you how old are you i'm 35.
35 years old 35 years old and you're a
business owner
uh-huh and what's your question
um so my issue is well
i want to know at what point when i'm
just meeting a guy do i tell him that
i'm a business owner because
um my problem is that when i try to
date down and i the conversation comes
up to where i
own the business um the guy is either
like
hey can i come join in on you on that
business
or can i put some money and be a
business partner and
i'm not looking for that and i honestly
oh
hold on hold on hold on hold on i need
to be clear on this subject
where are you where are you at north
carolina
and you're saying when to tell somebody
you own a business
because um i find when i date down
god to your interest and want to be like
a business partner
and i'm i'm learning that maybe i need a
high value name because that's
well first off um before i start do you
know what the term high value man means
like have you heard that before
no okay it basically means they have to
make six figures they have to like
i think height might be a part of it but
i'm not sure
um and they have to like
have a certain like social status as
well like they have to have like a group
of people that they're useful to
we could go to like the actual
definition but it's definitely like
money
but is it money like income because like
you could make
you know six figures but it doesn't mean
you're managing your money well so is
that part of it um
no well he's never really talked about
that i just know it starts at six
figures okay so she needs a six-figure
man
yeah ma'am i really understand
uh what kind of man are you talking
about
because owning a business is no
different than having a job in my
opinion
i'm not getting what you're saying when
should you i'm not understanding why
this is an
issue if you're if you're what kind of
men are you
what kind of men are you dating um
i try to give i try to give guys that
not just you try to do what
i try to get guys that's not on my level
a chance
why what do you mean on your level what
does that mean
that's making six figures or more
but i don't under okay you try to give
guys who are
not on your level a chance before i keep
going do you think
income's important in dating like in who
you date
no i would say money management is more
important than income sorry yeah yeah
i agree wow
because i want i honestly want a six
figure guy
is what i'm realizing okay so let me
just go ahead and net it out for you
you ready uh-huh
the guys you want aren't asking you out
well i'm i haven't been putting myself
out there honestly
but you put yourself out there enough
for the guys you don't want or
believe you to ask you out those are
like guys i met online
right so again
the men you want are not asking you out
see you ladies do this you go
and deal with men who you feel are
beneath you
and then you ask how to fix them i'm not
beneath you
i don't know how to fix a guy that
doesn't that's down there that's not my
concern
the better question is why can't you get
a guy on your level
that's the real question well the point
well first of all i would tell you what
i said
in here automatically is a problem why
you would come onto a show that you know
was a disagreement day
it's selfish it's like well
yes man it's sell it's like i want what
i want
i don't i don't say things for no reason
that's why i asked you questions you're
35 years old a business owner
that means you understand what business
is and you know this is a business
and i have a and i have a show title and
you said
damn your show title i want to talk to
you
but you could have went to my business
and booked time to talk to me but you
wanted what you wanted how you want it
i'm sorry no it's but and i'm using this
as a lesson that's the problem with too
many of you black women you don't do
[ __ ] the right way with black men
that was improper and when i even when i
told you the right way
you still were like well whatever
what do you think so he's reaching
because he could have easily just said
no today is not the day for that i feel
like he's reaching he's trying to make
an analogy where it's not one
i don't feel like that's a common
problem with black women or black men
he um like i get what he's saying like
this was a day that he had
a certain type of show he should have
just said i'm not gonna see you why is
he
dragging it on like okay you've already
let her go i actually agree with you
i would say like he definitely should
have like ended
this like way earlier yeah if you don't
want to do it like
i don't know but at the same time like
it's a show
yeah she knows what she's calling into
that's true like
i don't know i always i always see both
sides
so let me use this was the last time you
had a relationship
um like the end of last year around
december how long did it last
a year a year uh and was that man
uh did you go to college
did i go to college yes
no sir okay how long have you owned your
own business
nine years and how and how long have you
been making six figures or more
last three okay why do you need a man
making six figures
um because i'm finding out that the guys
that i date that's not
is not working out what does that have
to do with money
because i feel like um
i need a god that i can respect and
admire
and i'm ambitious ambition and i want a
guy
that has that drive too and when he
doesn't i find myself
you know encouraging like hey babe you
can do this and you can do that
and then right so in north carolina
how what percentage of the population
what percentage of men in this country
make
six figures or more i think it's like
five percent i'm not closer to ten
so ten percent all right so
the question is what do those men who
make that kind of money
who all women tend to want what do they
want
i feel like they want arm candy somebody
who can um
have more to bring to the table than
just looks but
um also bringing
balance to their life i feel like i can
help them out
on um okay slow down what do you think
guys want
i'm just curious like in general or like
i give you a lot of money
yeah guys that make a lot of money let's
say i feel like they want someone that
like
understands how busy they are they want
somebody that
yeah looks nice but it's deeper than
that because it's like a lot of women
that look nice they want someone to make
them feel
like wanted and feel secure and like you
know they can be
leaders i feel like you know leaders in
the relationship like the men can be
leaders
yeah okay no i'm not i would agree with
that
like a lot of what you said you said
they won't arm candy then you
contradicted yourself
what they want somebody to do i know
what she's trying to say yeah she's
trying to say like obviously they have
to be hot
right they have to be hot but she's
saying not just arm candy yeah i mean
think about it like a lot of men who are
like billionaires or millionaires or
whatever they do want someone that looks
nice and they feel
you know can get dressed up clean up
well mm-hmm
yeah arm candy but something about you
know brain with it
and you know more in dale do you own do
you know any men who make six figures or
more
my dad and my uncle do you
excuse me do you know any men that you
are related to to make six figures or
more
unrelated to yeah that you are not
related to
not on a personal level
so you don't know them you don't know
what they want
but you want him man
i'm going to suggest that you really
don't know
what you want
and saying six figures is just something
that you've got taken from out there
but i'm not hearing this rooted to
anything
but what do you want ultimately do you
want to be married children what
yes i want to be married do you want any
children
yes how many um
i have a son you know so
how's your son he's 13 where's the
father
he's not enough anyway
i say where's the father well he's
not like in it like i would like him to
be
all right so um go ahead and take this
down ma'am
men who make the kind of money you're
talking about have options
and typically i don't want to deal with
women who are
have 13 year old sons who are used to
dating men who
this doesn't sound appealing
to the cop so what do you think so far i
think
do you think he's spitting fat so do you
think he's full of [ __ ] i think he's
full of [ __ ] okay completely full of
[ __ ] like
what are you talking about like she's
like she's asking the wrong types of
questions like
she already said he wasn't in the
picture i just feel like he's full of
[ __ ] like those high value men
don't necessarily not want to date
someone who has a 13 year old i would
argue if anything they prefer someone
who has a child that's older
you know what i'm saying more
independent like 13 is a teenager
so you're gonna date somebody with a kid
like i'd rather date somebody with the
kid i feel like
at that age yeah that's like like an
infant or like you know like a teenager
versus a kid but
i actually i think what he's saying is
true about the kid i don't think if you
have the choice like
between kids or no kids you pick kids
but i feel like at her age like she's
you're 23 she's
sure you're 24 she's 35 so if you get 35
in that dating
range you're gonna most likely find
people that have kids right but if you
have a guy that's like say 40
right or 35 to 40. and he wants to date
a girl
that's 35 with one kid or a girl that's
35 with no kid
like which one do you think he's gonna
pick i don't feel like it's that
important to them i don't really
i feel like it would only make a
difference if like the kid was younger
or if you're going to be dealing with
like arguments between the
the kids dad and she just said the dad
wasn't in the picture mm-hmm so
so do you would you if men like certain
were surveyed and they said like this is
something we care about would you then
change your opinion
if like we surveyed men and then like
there was a study that came out and it
said like we care about this we don't
want to date
possibly but you know some of those
studies are off because it's like
they're not they're not taking into
account
like are we surveying like men that make
over a certain amount yeah like let's
say it was
men over like in the ten percent like a
hundred thousand
um yeah i think so okay i was just
curious
there's no study i'm sure you know what
manosphere let us know in the comments
if there's a study
like that but i was just curious if that
would change because it's like there's
more factors than that like i feel like
that would play a part like okay does it
does the
relationship with the dad mm-hmm and
does is they how old is the kid
right like what are you gonna be dealing
with and then when it comes to income i
feel like they just want someone who's
on their level as far as income because
they don't want to
feel like they're getting taken
advantage of they don't want like
they're dating someone who's just in it
for the money
so she's saying she makes sense i don't
think they care
i think because like how many
billionaires date models
models don't make a lot of money right
but we're talking billionaires i'm
talking about like she
said six figures i feel like someone
who's making sick figures wants to get
with someone who makes
six figures or has the income potential
to make that much so they can grow
together they're worried about like
their assets and generational wealth
yeah no i don't think so actually no i
wish
like that would be like what you think
would be better yeah yeah like
because you can always change that right
like your income true but i feel like
at a certain level then maybe you stop
caring because i feel like once you have
so much money at that point you're like
okay
make a difference right okay cool
you're talking about do you understand
what i'm saying
yeah but um i was thinking once i start
booking session with you
that um i can't change men i know but i
can approve myself and i feel like i
have a lot to offer to those type of me
okay but see you should have stopped
right there
i just told you i cannot change men and
you said once i book a session with you
i'm not a miracle worker i'm telling you
what they want
and you're still saying yeah but i want
them
they don't want you
but i have been working on myself this
year and um
okay ma'am but okay 35
13 year old son with a sketchy father
why would a man who's in the top 10 of
earners
who women across the country want
want that um
because i have a lot to offer um
i feel like would you want your son
to if you had a son making that kind of
money
would you want him to bring home a woman
who had a 13 year old son
from a sketchy father or would you
prefer him to get a woman who had no
children
who's younger and easier to get on his
program
depending on his age this is this
see see what i mean see what i mean this
goes so deep for black women
they will even that should have been an
easy question
no i would not want my son to bring i
want the best for my son
that should have been the appropriate
answer that's why i sat
up that is [ __ ]
you should want the best for your son of
course
but this is but and are you thinking
see that's where i disagree this [ __ ]
that's where i disagree because just
because someone has
a kid because they're 35 just because
the dads aren't in their life like that
doesn't mean
make them not ideal like that doesn't
mean they're not the best what about
everything else
kind of person they are what kind of
moms they have know how they're going to
treat your son like i feel like he's a
little
like his focus is so narrow right and
then i
why is he why is he saying that's the
problem with black women like i hate
when people generalize like that
yeah because really never mind keep
going
but this is what i actually like
the way i see it is he's saying like
these guys aren't going to take the time
to get to know you so even if you have
those other stuff
like i don't think a lot of guys there's
a certain group of guys that aren't
going to get to know you just because
you have a kid
even if you have all those great
qualities maybe but i feel like just
like just like there's a certain group
of women that won't deal with guys
like that have a kid too maybe but i
feel like out of all men i don't think
that's a high number i feel like
you in order to meet men you have to be
like in the spaces that they are i feel
like where she's failing already like if
she was on my show that i don't have but
if
she was on my show i would tell her she
needs to be trying to go to the spaces
where
the kind of men she wants not on not on
dating apps necessarily because a lot of
times
i don't know i do feel like good quality
men are not on dating apps a lot of
times
that's the problem you all think you're
the exception to the rule but but your
life is proven to you that you're not
my love life is not that good i agree
with you that's
my point and ma'am and that's my point
you ladies all feel like listen
you ladies all feel like you're the
exception to the rule
and then you remember you said he was
nice at the beginning
i looked at the camera i was like she
doesn't even know who comes along and
gives you
a a dose of reality instead of just
accepting it it's like yeah but
yeah but i'm special you don't
know any men on this level
that are not your father that aren't
related to you that means you don't know
these men
you don't know where to go get them you
don't know what they want
but you're still saying pick me they
don't want
mid 30 year old baby mamas they're
trying to be polite man but they don't
want
that's polite that's his version of
being polite
that's him trying to be polite oh my
gosh i hate to see how he's in his room
do you hear what i said yes
why is that so okay
go ahead um
my from my point of view i feel like i
get what you're saying they they do have
better options but also those better
options
are younger girls those younger girls
don't necessarily
are necessarily 20 year olds are not
necessarily attracted to 45 year olds
[ __ ] i'm 51. i i can't beat him off
with a stick
that's another one on you lies no
younger women are always
younger women are attracted to the older
men what are you talking about i've
never been into the older guy thing have
you
yeah me either and the other thing you
never got it yeah but the other thing is
like the maturity level is not going to
be where you're feeling like stimulated
so his he's got a moot point so can you
see me
yes i can okay so do you feel like a
woman like me
uh-huh what would you rank yourself on a
scale from one to ten
you cannot use seven what i rate myself
just your face uh my face when i wake up
five but when i put myself together six
okay
and how tall are you five five
dress size i'm sorry your dress size
okay so that makes you if you give
yourself a five
that's average yes so
average looking women tend not to get
high earning men
they tend to get average men
so um did you did you i mean stop right
there
stop right there stop right there
breathe and digest
you're 35 years old and you can look
around
and see the world you don't tend to see
higher earning men with average looking
women
off rip if you do see them
they got them they got their average
looking woman when they were both
really young and he built his way up but
a man earning the kind of money you're
talking about
does not go for an average looking woman
i mean my body is not average so but
ma'am you please don't make me say it
say what
i really just wanted some advice i love
you i'm giving you i'm giving you advice
but you're not
taking it the advice is man man
you're average looking at best
i'm taking it in but okay but you're not
accepting the fact
that okay
oh my god people watch him he's popping
he's very like he's
he's growing like he's gonna hit a
million on youtube soon
that is crazy this is the clip that made
him viral that is crazy
and that is so like i feel like he's
saying a lot of inaccurate stuff
like how can he look at her and say like
okay she's average looking like how do
you know that
somebody doesn't look at her and find
her very beautiful and i'm
a little concerned like what exactly
about her is making him say that she's
not
you know beautiful or not above average
like what about her exactly makes her
average looking
so that's very relative well not to
mention that she's she's a high income
earner i could see if she wasn't making
no money
that's different okay you're not making
any money and you're aspiring to be with
someone who makes a lot of money
but she has her own business had it for
a lot of years even without college like
that is taken into consideration i feel
like i don't think it is
like from all of the stuff like i listen
to hours and hours and hours
of guys talk about like what they want
they say like like
income to men is like a shoe collection
to women
it's like when the guy has a shoe
collection we think it's cool
but like we don't really care yeah but i
feel like at that level when you're
making six figures you want someone that
can build wealth with you you don't want
someone who's gonna just
you know what i'm saying like much off
of that yeah i mean i hear you
i just like the more like that i had a
similar reaction to you when i first
watched this
but the more i like asked like even um
like my dad he's in like the top
percentage of mad like
what like guys want like similar stuff
like he
he's sad like similar things that kevin
says really
yeah which isn't like he said it's harsh
right
my dad's not an [ __ ] like he's a nice
guy but he even
like like my mom did what he said like
because there's not an age gap between
them or i need like five years but
nothing crazy
right but like my mom got with my dad
when he was young
and then this like stayed with him yeah
but like so you think like face is what
matters because she was talking about
her body and he's like no it's
your average looking no i don't think
it's face i think it's like
well they say it's like feminine
friendly
likes to be like fit like being in shape
right feminine
like having like feminine
energy i don't really get that one
completely but like cooking for a guy
cleaning for a guy like that's the stuff
that
apparently according to the manuscripts
are guys like and friendly so just being
nice
and like easy to get along with which i
would agree with that part i think being
nice helps a lot because i've been told
by men like
that's what they like about me like oh
you're saying all your time so yeah but
i don't know about the others
um but like what he's saying is he's not
saying like no one will love you no one
will be with you and this is what took
me a while to understand
he's saying that like like why don't you
give some of the average guys a chance
so guys like 60 70 80. like those are
still above average incomes but she
won't even look at them
not because they're not kind not because
they're not a good character just
because they don't have a certain amount
of money but is that wrong
not to want someone who's a similar
income range as her like you're saying
you think that's
not right i mean i i think you're
allowed to want what you want
you know what i mean like you can want
whatever you want but like they'll say
like it's shallow for guys to only look
at looks but girls look at income and
that's nothing to do with your character
i think it's different when you're
looking at income and you're lucky and
you don't have the income
you're looking at someone with a similar
income is different than you you know
making 60 000 and being like i want
someone who's yeah
right no i hear you and i wish like
genuinely i wish it was like
i don't know i that's just like my
opinion though you know
like like from listening to what guys
say they want
but i would be more than open to like if
you had a guy that wanted to come here
and react
i want to yeah i want to have i want to
have bobby come on
because he makes these figures so i
would want to hear yeah yeah
actually that would be great yeah so i
would actually yeah i'm going to see
because that may be good yeah average
looking women
average looking woman who's older
average looking older woman with a 13
year old
oh they care about age a lot that's what
they said
so you could be like average but if
you're young it's cool
why though oh kids
because it's like they're like
programmed to like want kids yeah but
people are having kids older and older
now
and it's like you're gonna i don't know
i feel you're gonna disengage you're not
gonna be as interested in a
younger girl unless she's really mature
because what are you guys going to talk
about
like him at 50 like being with a 25 year
old you're a totally different
life experience i agree i think that
would be very boring i wouldn't want it
right like that for me yeah like you
wouldn't be with someone who is 50 years
old right now
but like no of course not but i'm saying
like
i can't discount the fact that
billionaire like like you take the
richest of the rich they do it all the
time
yeah like there's a reason for it i
can't like i can't like be blind to the
fact that like
the billionaires will get these models
and oprah doesn't have men line up to
date her
does she though does she not i think a
lot of ben would want to be with her
yeah but i don't think like it's not the
same like
she's not seen like a sex symbol like
some of the billionaire men who are who
might not be traditionally
yeah yeah that's like that's i can't
like ignore that like i wish it wasn't
how it was
right but you're just saying facts yeah
i'm just saying like what i see
you know average looking woman with a 13
year old son with a sketchy baby
i would never say it like that like i'm
nicer
this gets worse every time i hate it on
the show when i see girls on his show
like this guy has a million subscribers
or like a ton of followers
if you don't want to be on that's fine
but get off yourself that's just
irritating now you're
asking for a man who's in the top 10 of
men
you don't qualify for one
and you're making i mean i don't i don't
want to have to go there
but when you put in the all these other
factors
why can't you just get a man that's an
average guy
sometimes i feel like um
in order to fully submit i have to feel
like he's in
well then you're gonna then you're gonna
die alone how about that all right let
me just cut to the chase man
he says that you can tell what you want
to but women like you die alone
straight up because you think you're
better than the men that you qualify for
and the only reason honestly ma'am that
i can see a woman like yourself
really thinking you deserve more is
because you earn more because you earn
more money than most people around you
in north carolina
but if your ass worked at the post
office you would not think so highly
of your opportunities
and that's the reality we don't men
don't care about your money
not the kind of mean that you want we
don't care about your money
it ain't ours we care about the fact
that you are older
and you got kid
and you're average
damn and your reality of your life has
showed you that you don't have the kind
of meaning that you want
knocking on your door trying to find you
see what we've done in this country this
world is we've told women like yourself
that you can have it all and you got a
prince
charming who's six foot a hundred
six feet tall six figure income jawline
all this other kind of stuff
yeah i'm sorry man no
most people get average people
especially average people
you're an average person i mean let's be
real
you're not running microsoft you got you
had a pet grooming business
but she's making six figures you've been
making sisters for the last three years
okay
but if i'm looking at you but if i
looked at you and i took all that off
for you
i can't imagine this girl did not know
that like
millions of people were going to see
this like he wasn't as big before this
clip this is like what made him famous
all the eyelashes and all the hair what
do you look like under there
i mean i look the same i'm just no you
don't
because if you did you wouldn't have all
that on i'm sorry
that's unfair you don't you don't that's
unfair
you think so yeah like a lot of women
wear makeup whoever like whatever
halle berry wears makeup and wears
eyelashes like that's not fair
she still looks like that she just looks
like you know enhanced but that doesn't
make her look like a totally different
person look how much makeup she's
wearing nothing crazy no i don't think
she's wearing anything crazy
yeah for him to say like you don't look
like that underneath but like
yeah yeah but i like i do agree that
like women wear that stuff to look
better
yeah and some some girls like that she
doesn't look super caked on
no her extensions kind of bother me like
i don't like the
probably i said a weave
i don't know i just it just looks like
bad extensions to me
like they don't like new no they just
look like
like like i don't know there's a
difference you can tell when it's like
good like
quality hair don't look the same because
if you did you wouldn't have all that on
so what is your advice for
uh all right i'll tell you my advice man
because you're not listen to me this is
why i always recommend you need to do
nitty-gritty therapy but you're not
you're not dealing with reality
i asked you about your child's father
and you couldn't answer me
but it doesn't sound like you're too
proud of him
how's it what kind of student is your
child
he's a student does he have any
behavioral problems
no he actually got a youtube channel and
he's trying to i don't need that i don't
need no no
no where's his eyes still
his daddy is alive i know he does like
white ass she's sharing you know what i
mean like
okay whatever he's real he's
relationship with his father
then what's your issue with him
um he's not um business minded like my
father and my uncle and
then why did you choose to make a baby
with him before you got married
young and dumb i was 16. exactly and
that cost
see that dumb [ __ ] let me stop you right
here that young and dumb [ __ ] you black
women throw out
as if it's supposed to give listen and
listen
white girls do that too well women
young and dumb is not a get out of jail
free card
it doesn't go woof and change the fact
you still have to carry that consequence
what about her success
what about her success though since that
happened obviously it's not ideal i have
a child when you're 16
out of wedlock but what about her
success what about her business like
yeah i think the only thing he's trying
to say is that like caught like there
are guys that won't date you now because
you have a kid
yeah but there are they're on that will
and i feel like there are some high
income earners that will
and i feel like she's not really giving
her like advice that's what i always say
he
focuses too much on the problem yeah
instead of giving her a solution
like solution i hope he sees this dude
i don't know maybe i hope so hi kevin
are not rushing up to be stepfathers to
13 year olds
like i just hate it when she's on her
phone
because if you honestly sat down and
asked yourself what value
can i bring to a man and i know that
what i can
well all right what can what value
what what is it what is it
i can help him with his business i'm
very business minor on the
um end of health and organizer and
i plant um into planting my own garden
so i can definitely plant i'm into
um improving my elegance with um
just self-improvement and working on
myself
and ma'am at 35 years old at 35 years
old here's what you told me
i can help him with his business do
respect ma'am
um and i mean no disrespect but 20 to 30
percent of people own businesses what
about the 70 to 80
of men who don't own them that means
that doesn't matter
that means nothing to the average man
then the next thing you said i can plant
man that means nothing to most people
because we go to
grocery stores then you say
self-improvement you've had i gave you a
shot at saying what you have to offer to
me
and you said nothing that we value
what do you buy what no booking session
bigger session book a session
i'm not doing this nope nope nope i'm
done i'm done
i've tried to go around but this happens
the older you ladies get the more you
get set in your ways book a session
because i don't want to do this in
public man
cause you seem like a sweet woman but
you don't but you're not getting it
you're being so mean i'm not being don't
tell me i'm being mean
well i'm about to be honest i get tired
of you broads
telling me i'm being mean because you
cannot handle the damn truth
you called my show on the day the
training was supposed to be here
and i honored the call and sat here and
tried to help you and i'm telling you
telling me i'm being mean
the [ __ ] out of my phone
damn
so funny you're beginning to like now
i knew i knew we started the video so
tell tell the audience your final
thoughts what did you like and what do
you dislike
you do agree with something he said i
like what he wore
okay i like to do more
that's it i i'm trying to think i like
what he wore and uh
i agree you should know what you have to
offer i do agree with that i think
before you get out into dating you
should know what you have to offer
i disagree with a lot i disagree with
the fact that he called her abroad i
disagree with the fact
that he you know caught her average
looking i disagree with the fact that he
says
money is not important at all to men who
make six figures
i feel like once we get to a certain
level
it doesn't matter but for most people
they would also like someone who makes
six figures so they could build together
yeah see i like don't think they care
like genuinely like i have brothers that
are on their way to making six figures
like they want girls that are smart like
that that's something they've told me
but like
and then i think he didn't he didn't
take into consideration so she said oh
i'm business minded he said oh summoned
on the business but it's like
being a business minded helps you with
other things it helps you with like
you know for them to buy a house
together and like you know with your
personal finances
yeah so i feel like that stuff matters
to them it's not just
okay i want my business my okay my
audience is 95
men so i want everyone to leave a
comment and let me know what you think
like top five things that are not in the
manosphere that men value
so like not fit not feminine friendly i
know what those are
let me know five things you value not
including that
anything else you want to add you know
no i don't know
well thanks so much for coming on this
was fun that was fun um do not forget to
subscribe to the channel
help me get to 20 000 subscribers bring
that notification bell for daily
notifications
and i will talk to you guys next time